a few years ago this broken ass system
marked me as a criminal risk like me to
some [ __ ] I didn't even do because it
was probable ones in the system always
in the system the amount of personal
data that thing is collecting is
mind-blowing violating the public trust
manipulating the stock markets the lies
the fraud I say together we tear down
the wall the undeniable
alright you need two things to take down
bloom need to get people to rally behind
you cause to separate you from the
trolls and we need bots and a lot of
them to handle the data sea to us is
processing you can get followers to
download the app you can use their
processing power for the cause
distracting enough for you barbarians
are at the gate ready to bust some Roman
head and swinging my entire truth
we
I have friends that would love to put
dead sack behind bars you're fighting a
war no one gives a [ __ ] about I'm so
aggressive so indignant oh oh oh and
there's a warrant out for your arrest we
will not be right to
we undeniable we will not be afraid we
will not
numbers haven't stopped going Oh what
are we gonna do aim bigger watch
youtubers play watch dogs to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and be the first
to see new trailers and
behind-the-scenes action